the jackass family was never the same
after the death of ryan dunn who died
aged 34 in a devastating car crash his
life till then was an inspiration but it
was also filled with trouble and signs
of the tragedy to come
born in 1977 ryan dunn moved multiple
times over the course of his childhood
he began his life in ohio went to new
york and finally ended up in
pennsylvania it was there that dunn
attended high school and met bam margera
the two became fast friends and remained
close throughout dunn's life soon after
graduation dunn snagged his first acting
role playing a soldier in the 1996
sci-fi movie life form however it wasn't
until 1999 that he began to do what made
him famous that's when he began working
with margera on the cky videos that
would become the foundation of which
jackass grew jackass itself arrived on
mtv in 2000 and dunn was there from the
start he appeared in all 25 episodes of
the series and went on to do stunts in
jackass the movie jackass number 2 and
jackass 3d he appeared in other projects
with members of the jackass crew
including stevo and most prominently his
friend bam margera he acted as well but
not as often and typically in small or
independent projects that got less
attention than his jackass work
in 2005 police pulled over dunn while he
was operating a motor vehicle they
deduced his level of intoxication at the
scene and eventually the town charged
him with the dui in his late 20s at the
time this was his first recorded
incident of driving under the effects of
a substance given that the court
determined dunn was an appropriate
candidate for the first time offenders
program an opportunity which he pursued
this pre-trial diversion program would
typically allow a motorist facing
charges to avoid jail time receive
reduced license suspension time or have
the charges eliminated entirely and
eventually have their record cleared
dunn completed the program as prescribed
he still did have his license suspended
for over a year which is around the
standard for first-time dui offense in
pennsylvania however the offenders
program ensured the charges against him
were dropped after he completed the
probationary period
in addition to his 2005 dui ryan dunn
had quite a few problems when it came to
sitting behind the wheel as noted in a
philadelphia inquirer piece from 2011
the stunt performer had a reputation
when it came to driving
pulled over
how fast
167 was it
the jackass star was known for loving
speed and adrenaline while in a car and
had a tendency to be relaxed about
safety in jackass and participating in
gumball 3000 events international races
that took place on public roads and
frequently attracted celebrity
participants he found lucrative and
somewhat approved ways to express
himself unfortunately he often didn't
turn off the need for speed when it came
to getting around in his day-to-day life
this approach to driving didn't escape
law enforcement's notice in the 13 years
from 1998 to 2011 dunn racked up 23
violations three of those times he was
pulled over and charged for driving with
a suspended license and 10 stops earned
him tickets for speeding and reckless
driving after dunn's death van margera's
mother april recalled constantly warning
him about his driving habits
he drove too fast and i yelled at him
all the time about that
in the closing stunt of jackass number
two the plan was for a horse to pull
ryan dunn and bam margera off their feet
and then out of view visually the scene
went as planned but the physical
consequences for dunn were anything but
routine when dunn went to the ground he
landed on his shoulder his muscles in
that area took the full force of the
impact an immediately painful
consequence however the repercussions of
the fall proved worse than the typical
kinds of bruises and breaks the jackass
gang had grown to accept the damage from
the fall was serious enough to cause a
blood clot which was potentially
life-threatening as jackass number two
director jeff tremaine explained in an
mtv tribute to dunn the damage was much
more serious and lasting than it may
have looked on screen you know blood
clot is really dangerous because if a
chunk of that went into his heart or
into his brain he would die
in the same mtv tribute friend cameron
taylor said dunn was actually quite
frightened explaining he'd never seen a
man more scared and that dunn could have
died at any minute fortunately dunn
received treatment that saved his life
but things were about to get even worse
for the stuntman
the hits kept coming for done while
receiving treatment for his blood clot
dunn was diagnosed with lyme disease in
an interview with film threat in 2010
dunn confirmed the diagnosis and his
recovery although he didn't offer any
insight into when or where he came into
contact with the infected tick that
passed him the virus while his treatment
for lyme proved successful the
combination of the blood clot the
disease and the long recovery process
seemed to add up in the same interview
where he revealed his history with lyme
dunn attempted to downplay it is just
taking a break after 10 years of work
subsequent publications however have
confirmed depression was an ongoing
struggle for the actor and stunt
performer in fact he slipped into such a
significant depression that he cut
himself off from contact with many of
his friends including the jackass crew
for two years
despite the way it came about the hiatus
from performing seemed to do done some
good he returned to the world of
reckless and hilarious stunts in jackass
3d and appeared happy to be back he
referred to the experience as his
favorite on-screen work experiencing
early apprehension about returning only
to find the same camaraderie he always
had with the team came as a relief and
led to the most fun he had making a
jackass film he booked three acting jobs
in the same year and also produced his
first film living will in which he was
also cast as the lead role
i'm eating everything i can until i poop
he even struck off on his own to co-host
a show on g4 with jessica chalbot his
first prominent tv work without any
members of the jackass crew the show
proving ground involved attempting to
replicate pop culture experiences in
real life for instance an early episode
tried to realize the mario kart
experience given duns established stunt
bonafides and his prominent place in pop
culture it seemed a promising fit for
the first time in years dunn's career
prospects seemed on track
on june 19th 2011 dunn was back in his
hometown and celebrating joining him for
a night on the town was zachary hardwell
a longtime friend who also worked as a
production assistant on jackass number
two
sometime around 2 30 the next morning
the two decided to call it quits but as
dunn was driving with hartwell in the
car he soon hit speeds in excess of 130
miles per hour in his porsche 911 gt3 he
seemingly lost control of the vehicle at
some point and collided violently with a
tree upon collision the car caught fire
and both he and hartwell were killed in
the accident the cause of death was
attributed to a combination of the
impact and the subsequent fire in
addition to the fact that he was coming
from a bar and that several social media
posts showed him drinking a toxicology
report confirmed dunn's intoxication at
the time of the crash with a blood
alcohol level around twice the legal
limit
zachary hartwell had known ryan dunn and
bam margera for several years in
addition to peeing on jackass number two
he done stunt driving on the film ming
hex which was written and directed by
margera and starred marjara and dunn
additionally hartwell was an iraq war
vet he served two tours overseas as a
navy gunner before returning to america
in 2010 hartwell married rachel his high
school sweetheart they were married less
than a year when hartwell died in the
car crash in august 2012 hartwell's
parents went to court seeking damages
they named dunn's estate as well as
barnaby's the bar where dunn was
drinking as defendants in the suit in
addition to wrongful death the lawsuit
alleged the parties behaved negligently
and recklessly and that those actions
led to the death of their son
despite the tragic consequences of his
actions dunn's death left many bereft
after all the man was beloved by many
both people in his personal life and
those who followed his adventures on the
screen as a result fans and friends met
the news of his death with an outpouring
of social media posts musical artists
like kings of leon and skrillex
dedicated songs from their concerts to
dunn's memory in the days after his
demise singer-songwriter roger allen
wade even wrote an original piece for
him which played at dunn's memorial
service in a special tribute video in
2013 the film jackass presents bad
grandpa hit theaters everywhere it was
the first big screen project from the
jackass crew since 2011 and dunn's
co-workers and friends dedicated the
project to their late friend in
commemorative and anniversary releases
the group has continued to feature dunn
in archival footage and despite his
tragic passing the man's legend still
lives on through his crazy work in the
world of jackass